- Good morning believe nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe!
And I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So, to help you on your journey,
today's message is keep
things in perspective.
Over to you Dalai Lama.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- [Woman] Do you believe
that your time on here,
on earth, has been a success?
- Success?
That all so relative.
Some feel it, in some which you can tell,
and some feel failure,
so difficult to say.
I hope all human life like that,
some part failure, some part achieve.
(laughs)
It is wrong, to pick up one thing,
then say all rest success is wrong.
And pick up one thing, of
failure, that also wrong.
Things are relative.
- I think one of the hardest things
that people have a hard
time grasping about me,
and the people on my team,
is the ability to pull from
both ends that seem opposite,
but really, I find, come together.
To be very humble, and
feel like I know nothing,
and also feel very confident,
and feel like I know a lot,
Right, just depending on
what the circumstances are.
And so, as an example,
look at my youtube channel.
I'm always struggling to
get better and feel like
I have a lot of work to do.
And I feel like, I have
a really good channel,
and I'm super proud of
everything that we've done.
Both, at the same time.
I hold both concepts in
my head at the same time.
And so, depending on who I'm talking to,
I might be really hard on myself.
I might be saying, my
channel, I need to get better.
I need to create better content.
I need to research to be better.
I need to be better in
front of the camera.
I need my editing to be better.
I need everything about
my channel to be better.
Because yeah, we've hit a quarter million,
or three quarters of million subscribers,
but I know I can do so much more.
I need to get really, really, really good.
I look at who else is out there.
I look at Les Brown, and Tony Robbins
and I see their ability to
connect and reach people,
and I want to do that.
I need to hone my skills and get better.
Just drive and improve.
And a lot of times people
look at me and say,
like, that's okay, this is crazy.
You should be proud of yourself,
like, look at what you've done.
You've got 100,000,000 views
on your youtube channel.
You've got 750,000 plus subscribers.
You're making three videos a day
where most people can't
even do one a week.
Like, why are you so hard on yourself?
Your channel's really good!
And then my default thinking is
well, I know my channel's amazing.
My channel's insanely good.
I think my channel's the
best channel in the world.
I think I might be the first
YouTuber to win a Nobel Prize
for entrepreneurship.
Like, it's awesome.
The work I'm doing is meaningful
and having a huge impact.
It's just pulling from both spectrums,
like I am so proud of everything
that me and my team make,
and so filled with confidence
in what we're doing,
and I know that the impact is real.
And, what we do sucks.
It isn't good enough.
It needs to get better, consistently.
I think that perspective helps.
I think you have to be able
to pull from both sides.
I think it applies to a
lot of things in life.
I look at leadership.
I look at the people under me on my team.
I look at sometimes I
need to push them harder.
Sometimes, they might
be like they're amazing
and you say, well, you know
what, you kind of suck.
Like, let's go, I know
you can do way better.
Sometimes, I need to
build them up and say,
listen, you're amazing, but why
are you so hard on yourself,
depending on what they need in the moment.
You know, Alex, who comes in
who's a part of Toronto Dance Salsa.
If he comes in and he's
really low and feeling down,
I need to build him back up and say,
you are really good, like,
you're a really good instructor.
You don't need to be that hard on yourself
because the negative energy prevents
him from doing amazing things.
Sometimes he comes in so hot, he's like,
I'm the best thing
ever, and you know what,
you suck, dude.
Like, here are all the things
that you need to off and get better at,
because the positive energy, again,
prevents him from going
off and doing great things.
When you can hold both,
when you can stay balanced,
when you can either be in the
middle or pull from both ends
at the same time, I think
that's where you not just have
more success, but you also
feel more grounded, more happy,
more secure, less concerned
about other people's thoughts,
less insecure about
yourself, and your ideas,
and where you're going.
So, finding ways constantly
to both be grateful
for everything you have.
I'm so grateful for everything in my life.
I think I have such an amazing life.
I don't want anybody
else's life out there.
I want my life.
I love this life, it's great.
And, I want to do more.
I want to help more.
I need to push harder.
So, it's both, constantly.
I think if you are only pushing,
only pushing, pushing, pushing, pushing,
then you're never happy.
You're never happy, and there's always
a place to push, right?
There's always something else you can do
when you're never happy
with what you've done.
And, if you're only happy,
and you're only grateful,
and you're only playing down here,
then you feel great and you feel blessed,
which is awesome, but then
you're not contributing enough.
Like, I feel if you have
the ability to help,
then you have a responsibility
to help as well.
If you have all this great
natural talent and ability,
and you're able to work hard to be able to
improve other people's
lives but you're not
because you're just
happy relaxed, laid back,
I don't think that's a
fulfilling life either.
I think you need both.
You need the gratitude
and you need the push,
that I'm not good enough.
I have everything I
need and I have nothing,
both, same time, right.
And so, keeping things in perspective,
I think, maybe, when people meet me
it's one of the hardest things
to wrap their heads around.
I'm having a discussion
still with Alex around today,
and he's still confused by
some of the things I'm saying,
and we've been working
together for a while now,
but I think it's super important.
And, if you can find that
perspective and keep that balance,
it'll help you be that
best version of yourself.
The question day-to-day is, I'm curious,
what are two opposite ideas
that you hold at the same time
that the outside world may look at you
and think you're crazy,
Like, how can you believe this, and this,
but you see them as just
opposite sides of the coin,
and you can hold both at the same time.
What are those two thoughts for you?
I'm really curious to find
out and I hope you'll share it
down in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Erik Peterson.
Erik, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
I really appreciate the support, man,
and I hope you enjoy the read.
So, thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- When you have a down time,
like your something didn't
work the way you want,
what do you do to get
back on that positiveness?
- I talk to the mountain.
I have a mountain next to my home
that is called wa-she-de-lay.
It goes up to two, it's very low.
It goes up to 2,000 and
four, or 2,500 meters.
Or I talk to the dom-de-me-de,
which is 4,000 meters,
which is a little bit
further away from my home,
which I see every morning.
I see those two mountains.
And I say to these two mountains,
mountain, I have a problem.
But, when I look at you,
you are 37 million old.
(laughing)
- I'm a little guy,
- you seem to be gay
and strong.
- I'm a little guy
here with little
problems, can you help me?
They would say, come on.
Look, what we have already
seen in so many years,
your problem is a none-no problem.
Come on, get up.
- Just get up, do it, that's it.
- 13 years ago you were
completely bust, gone, no money.
You had five pounds, you know,
seven dollars left in your hand.
You used it for a taxi
back to your parents.
And your career in the record business
had just come to a sudden shuddering halt.
Here you are, 13 years later, you're worth
hundreds of millions of dollars.
Life's taken a huge turn upwards,
but I get the sense with you
that what happened to you
13 years ago still defines you now.
- Yeah, I mean, it
wasn't the best of times,
but, then again, when I look back on it,
it wasn't the worst of times, you know.
Because, I think, particularly
here in Hollywood,
where most people get it wrong
is they're afraid of
losing what they've got.
They're just terrified
of losing their fame,
as you said, power, money.
But actually, once you've lost it,
you can always get it back again.
I mean, it's not the end of the world.
I mean, being ill's worse.
So, because I've actually faced
what are most people's worst fears,
and recovered from it, it's
not as bad as you think.
You know, I didn't lose my confidence.
My friends were still my friends.
I've lived with my parents.
I just saw it as a challenge
that I've got to get myself
back on my feet again.
- What advice do your
parents give you then?
- They were really, honest to god,
they were just cool about it.
They were parents.
They just wanted to look after me.
Lived with them for a while.
My dad lent me some money to pay the bank,
then eventually I managed
to pay my dad back.
You know, it was what any parent would do.
But, like I said, it wasn't
the worst time in my life,
and actually when I look back on it now,
I still smile because, you know,
I bought this beat up
old British sports car,
worked 18 hours a day, and
I was so determined, Piers,
just to get it right this time
'cause I knew why I'd got it wrong.
Now, I find it much easier
to deal with things.
- If that wasn't the worst
time in your life, what was?
- When my dad died was
the worst time in my life.
As you know, you and I discussed that.
It was just that, like,
getting ill, losing a parent
or losing somebody close to you,
that's the worst thing that
could ever happen in your life.
And all the things that I
worry about now, just trivial.
I mean, even the whole kind
of Idol, X Factor thing,
I laugh about it because it's
such a high-class problem.
My show's better than your show.
It's like, but we both got a show.
(both laughing)
- It's a bit like Colin
Firth and Hugh Grant
in the fountain in
Bridget Jones, fighting.
- Exactly, over what, I mean,
the fact that we're here, we
can do this, it's fantastic.
- Keep things in perspective.
I know we all say it, but really
you just have to keep reinforcing it.
Everyone in this audience, knock on wood,
you're going to do just fine.
You're going to have
your four-bedroom house.
You're going to have your
car with power windows.
You'll be able to go to Sea
World whenever you want to.
But, along that way, there
are going to be ups and downs.
And, actually, those ups
and downs tend to happen
a lot when you go to transition points,
when you're entering the workforce,
you're entering some type
of a new phase in your life.
You just always have to
keep on the long-term game,
the end game.
I'll tell you myself, I've gone through
some fairly dramatic ones
right when I was out the gate.
This was 1998, I had just graduated,
I was a few months older
than most of you all,
and some computer magazine
had seen something I had done,
and they wrote this neat profile about me.
They called it Future so Bright.
I saw that magazine, I
was very proud of it.
I was like, aw look, I'm set.
I have this career ahead of me.
I'm already profiled in a magazine.
And, frankly, I got kind of in to myself.
And, that's okay, you
can enjoy your successes,
but I really didn't have any perspective,
and, frankly, it was a
dangerous thing to happen.
To really put things in perspective,
and I'm happy it did happen,
two months later I switched jobs,
higher salary, I thought
I was on the fast track.
I had a new boss, and on
the first three days of work
he spent an hour just
completely castigating me.
Essentially, telling me that
I was not worth his time.
That I was incompetent as
far as he was concerned.
You can imagine, you
know, I was like a lot of,
successful whole life, fancy degrees
from fancy universities.
Two months ago I was
profiled in a magazine,
and then now all of the sudden,
almost not even 23 years old,
I was back in a hotel room
in the middle of nowhere crying.
Not knowing what I was
going to do with my life.
Convinced that it was all
the end of everything,
that everything was for naught.
You know, you get through them.
You wake up in the morning,
things look a little bit better.
A week later, things look a little better.
You start circulating your resume around.
I did find another job two months later.
And, it's okay.
The one thing I want to stress,
because I've gone through
ups and downs, and you
only have one perspective
for your own life, but I
suspect many of you all
are going to have higher
ups than I've had,
and many of you all are
going to have lower downs.
I worry about that sometimes.
The ones of you who have higher ups,
just keep them in perspective.
It's inevitable, some of
you are going to race ahead
and be so successful that none of us
can imagine it right now.
But, keep them in perspective.
Enjoy the successes, but
when your ego starts feeling
a little bit large, keep in mind
the sun will supernova one day.
The galaxies will collide.
We are these small little
mammals on this small planet,
or, you know, there's 200
billion stars in the galaxy,
in just our galaxy alone.
Just have peace in the little success.
When you have a hard time, and you will,
and those who go through painful periods,
you might stumble and start
your first few times out the gate,
also keep in perspective
that those stresses,
put them in perspective of the universe.
They are small.
They're going to be things
that you'll be able to
laugh about, talk about,
10, 15 years from now,
or hopefully 10, 15 days from now.